Oh
Oh April baby okay so I just solved in
this site that reverbs are in season now
finally I'm gonna make a pie I thought
you wanted to make pie
are you alright I have to say something
at me it's hard to say but I feel like
we've been hanging out too much lately I
mean it's been like oh the time every
day
are we even individuals anyone you know
or we just one fused brain we've reached
a tipping point and is the hurts part
but I think we need a break a friend
break where we take a week off of
talking texting phone conversation and
even IRL hangs no letters no cards a
friend break just for a week you know
what I kind of been feeling the same way
I think that this is a really great idea
you're kidding
that wasn't April Fool's you're my god
April Fool ah you got fooled beautiful
oh man I win I'm okay no you're we did
the same April Fool's oh my god I feel
even closer we got to hang out every day
forever other words gonna blow my brains
out not if I grow mine out first oh okay
I'm coming over
it sounds great see you soon no I didn't
you this must bowl
[Music]